welcome back to cbs mornings cbs news is
launching a new investigative series
that looks at the disturbing rise in
unsolved murder cases nationwide crime
without punishment is a joint
investigation between cbs stations
across the country and our investigative
team here in new york today in the u.s
there's about a 50-50 chance that a
killer will never be arrested after
taking someone's life especially if the
victim is hispanic or black for police
departments in cities like philadelphia
it's a huge challenge and the first of
three very powerful stories this week
chief investigative correspondent jim
axelrod went inside philadelphia's
homicide unit to see firsthand why it's
so hard to solve murder cases jim good
morning good morning there were more
than 500 homicides in philadelphia last
year and that is more than ever before
and still more than half remain unsolved
we wanted to see why so we visited the
philadelphia police department the
fourth largest in the country
and what we found were detectives
overloaded overwhelmed and wide awake on
a thursday morning at 4 00 a.m
it is just after dawn in philadelphia
this is going to happen pretty fast once
they get out
like they do two to three times every
week detectives from the city's homicide
unit along with a swat team
are raiding a house where they believe a
murder suspect is holed up
they are looking for the man getting out
of this car in this video who they think
then shot and killed an uber driver in a
case of mistaken identity
on this morning the raid is successful
yeah we have two suspects in custody
as they take two men wanted in
connection with the shooting into
custody philadelphia homicide detective
joe murray at this point are you feeling
optimistic so far so good but right now
it's it's we're off to a good start
murray and the five other detectives in
his unit spend each day confronting one
of the most troubling questions in law
enforcement today why do so many murders
now go unsolved and unpunished in
america for us it's the volume
562 homicides were committed in
philadelphia last year
that's about 11 each week it's the
number of murders and we just keep going
and going going it's just
the volume just comes in and it just
crushes you
in the 1960s police solved eight out of
every 10 murder cases in america today
it's barely one in two
nationwide it's
it's a 50 50 coin flip thomas hargrove
runs the murder accountability project a
non-profit that tracks the homicide
clearance rate that's how often the
police solve murder cases it has never
been this bad during the last seven
months of 2020
most murders went unsolved and that's
never happened before in america and
today everything changed technology is
the key as philadelphia's chief
inspector frank fenor told us more than
just gum shoe detectives combing a crime
scene for shell casings and button
holding witnesses just about every
murder has sometimes dozens of sources
of video these days the focus of the
first 48 hours after homicide the most
crucial stretch for investigators
is gathering video videos become our new
witness
[Music]
we visited philadelphia five days after
a shooting on south street a bustling
commercial center left three dead and 11
wounded the area is blanketed by video
surveillance during that time lead
investigator captain jason smith's team
gathered no less than 45 angles of the
shooting but this modern-day dragnet of
sweeping social media and canvassing
businesses for video
is time-consuming often requiring
warrants and subpoenas but it works
while they were showing us footage from
the south street shooting detectives got
word of two more arrests they're in
custody you just got word
just got word right now you feel that
the arrests were made so quickly because
of the video that you have without a
doubt
but for all the technology it's no match
for what cops and chiefs told our
investigative teams at cbs stations
across the country what hinders murder
investigations most is the breakdown
between police and communities of color
in a post-george floyd world there's a
trust factor that we lost along the way
and we try every day to build that trust
factor back up our investigative data
team analyzed unsolved murders across
the country
the rate of arrests over the last 30
years when the victim is white has risen
above 85 percent
watch how the rate declines when the
victim is hispanic
and even fewer arrests are made
when the victim is black
the disparity is stunning it is stunning
it's not just here it's not just here
danielle outlaw is the commissioner of
the philadelphia police department this
disparity isn't five or ten points no
this disparity is gaping yes
are black murders pursued as
aggressively yes as urgently yes with
the same amount of manchester
yes
again
why do you end up with this kind of
disparity it's obvious i'm a black woman
and i run the fourth largest police
department in the country what we need
is a collaborative effort in solving
these cases and an acknowledgement what
i think is there now
that it's going to take more than the
police
to clear these cases and sometimes it
sounds like
what's implicit is that the community of
color
needs to trust the police more no not at
all we're talking about historically
issues systemic inequities that
contribute to the mistrust and then also
things that the police have done and
we've gotten in our own way it has to be
a two-way street as it is with any
relationship
just an arrest is enough to move a
murder case into the cleared column even
if the suspect still awaits a hearing as
this man now is
this counts as a good day for the
beleaguered detectives in philadelphia
who don't have time to examine the
trends
they're too busy trying to reverse them
and tomorrow we're going to report on
the toll unsolved murders take on a
community we visit with a group of
mothers in jackson mississippi who know
the crushing pain of losing their child
and are struggling to find justice
you know jim when commissioner outlaw
says she understands these historical
issues systemic inequities that
contribute to the mistrust they
understand the issue the question is how
do you fix it going forward right her
point being uh and i what i was pressing
her on was why do you hear the community
has to do better the community has to do
better isn't it a question of the
community and the police understanding
the cooperation that's having that trust
that's right and so her point was yes i
agree it is not just the community of
color that needs to do better to solve
to elevate the rate of clearing murder
cases the police have to do better as
well yeah but it's hard when either side
trusts the other though and but there
are bruised feelings on both sides it's
very tough but it's tough to see the
disparity in black and white the way you
just showed it to us sure thank you jim